Virtual reality technology is not just for gamers. Over the last decade, research into advanced virtual reality therapy techniques has shown it to be effective for people with physical and psychological disabilities. A psychologist at the forefront of this research tells us how virtual reality is helping people literally face their fears and learn to overcome them. I'm Audrey Hamilton, and this is Speaking of Psychology. Skip Rizzo is the director for Medical Virtual Reality at the International. Institute for Creative Technologies and a research professor at the University of Southern California.
虚拟现实技术不仅属于游戏玩家。在过去的十年里，对先进虚拟现实治疗技术的研究表明，它对身体和心理残障人士是有效的。站在这一研究前沿的一位心理学家告诉我们，虚拟现实如何帮助人们真正面对恐惧并学会克服它们。我是奥黛丽·汉密尔顿，这里是《心理学话语》。斯基普·里佐是国际创意技术研究所的医学虚拟现实主任，也是南加州大学的研究教授。
He conducts research on the design, development, and evaluation of virtual reality systems, focusing on clinical assessment, treatment rehabilitation, and resilience. Welcome, Dr. Rizzo. Hi. Thank you for having me here. Your work in developing virtual reality therapies focuses on combining advancements in computer technology with psychological science. How is virtual reality therapy being used in clinical settings right now? Right now, the biggest use of virtual reality in clinical settings is probably an area of exposure therapy,
他从事虚拟现实系统设计、开发和评估的研究，重点关注临床评估、治疗康复以及心理韧性。欢迎您，里佐博士。你好。谢谢你邀请我来。你在开发虚拟现实疗法方面的工作重点是将计算机技术的发展与心理科学相结合。虚拟现实疗法目前是如何在临床环境中应用的？目前，虚拟现实在临床环境中最大的应用可能是在暴露疗法领域，
and that is probably because the technology is well matched to the needs of the clinical application. We see with exposure therapy the goal really is about helping a patient, whether it's due to a simple phobia or PTSD, to engage, to confront and to process difficult traumatic memories. Now, in the traditional format, you typically do that in imagination alone, but when you have a disorder where avoidance is one of the cardinal symptoms, sometimes patients may need a little extra boost. So if we can put them in simulations that mimic or resemble some of their traumatic experiences and do it in a gradual yet progressive hierarchical fashion, then it really is well matched to what the need of the clinical approach is. Can you give us an example of how exposure therapy works and how the virtual reality therapy works in this type of therapy? Well, exposure therapy has been around for quite some time. It's a behavioral approach that's been applied initially for persons having fear of heights, fear of flying, fear of spiders.
这可能是因为该技术非常符合临床应用的需求。我们看到，对于暴露疗法，其真正的目标是帮助患者——无论是由于简单的恐惧症还是创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）——去接触、面对并处理困难的创伤记忆。现在，在传统的模式下，你通常只能通过想象来做到这一点，但是当你遇到一种以回避为核心症状之一的障碍时，有时患者可能需要一点额外的推动力。因此，如果我们能将他们置于模拟情境中，模拟或类似于他们的一些创伤经历，并以循序渐进、逐步升级的层级方式进行，那么它确实非常符合临床需求。你能给我们举个例子，说明暴露疗法是如何运作的以及虚拟现实疗法在这种疗法中是如何运作的吗？嗯，暴露疗法已经存在相当长一段时间了。这是一种行为方法，最初应用于有恐高症、恐惧飞行、恐惧蜘蛛的人。
And the therapist typically guides the patient in imagination to gradually get closer and closer to what it is that they fear. and by a process of extinction learning, which is basically face your fear and it becomes less frightening once you're actually confronted by it. What happens is patients lose that sort of irrational fear. Now we're talking about fears that aren't real, in real life kinds of fears. I mean, we're not trying to get somebody to jump in through traffic or, you know, do swim with sharks or anything like that. that. We're talking about things like we're, you know, somebody that lives in New York City but has a fear of snakes and they won't leave their house, even though there's probably very unlikely
而且治疗师通常会引导患者在想象中逐渐接近他们所恐惧的事物。通过消退学习的过程，这基本上就是面对你的恐惧，一旦你真正面对它，它就会变得不那么可怕。发生的情况是，患者失去了那种不理智的恐惧。现在我们谈论的是那些并非现实生活中那种真实的恐惧。我的意思是，我们并不是想让某人跳进车流，或者，你知道的，和鲨鱼一起游泳之类的。我们谈论的是这样的事情，比如，你知道的，一个住在纽约市的人对蛇有恐惧症，他们甚至不肯离开家，尽管可能极不可能
chance there's any snakes in LA, I mean in New York, aside from Wall Street. But maybe I should have a better example there. You know, these are fears that debilitate people and functioning in their everyday life. So the fear of flying, you know, it's pretty safe to fly. compared to driving in a car actually. But people that are fearful of flying, if they do exposure therapy, typically you get a very good treatment response where they confront that fear in the therapy session
洛杉矶会有任何蛇，我的意思是纽约，除了华尔街之外。但也许我应该举个更好的例子。你知道的，这些是削弱人们日常生活功能的恐惧。所以害怕坐飞机，你知道的，坐飞机其实挺安全的。相比开车其实还要安全。但是害怕坐飞机的人，如果他们做暴露疗法，通常你会得到非常好的治疗反应，他们在治疗期间直面这种恐惧，
and it carries over to their real life. And VR, what we try to do is to help that process along by putting people in simulations of their feared environment and then systematically making it a little bit more provocative once they've attained a certain level. So if it's fear of flying, they're in a plane and they're flying along. They can turn their head and look around, see the passenger, look next to them, look out the window.
并且这种效果会延续到他们的现实生活中。而对于VR，我们试图通过将人们置于他们所恐惧的环境的模拟中来帮助这个过程，然后在他们达到一定水平后系统地使其更具刺激性。因此，如果是恐高症或恐飞行，他们就在飞机上飞行。他们可以转头环顾四周，看到身边的乘客，看看窗外。
But then once they've gotten through that, then maybe you want to introduce a little turbulence or a thunderstorm, and we can do that with the technology and make it a little bit more scary. And the longer we can get the patient to stay with it, all of a sudden that fear kind of fades away. It extinguishes, as we call it. psych literature. And it carries over from the virtual environment, which is very similar to the real world in a lot of ways, so that people can now start taking flights and not being as
但一旦他们熬过了这一关，也许你想引入一点湍流或雷雨，我们可以用这项技术做到这一点，让它变得更吓人一点。只要我们能让患者坚持更长时间，突然之间那种恐惧就会消退。正如我们在心理学文献中所称的那样，它消退了。并且它从虚拟环境中延续下来，虚拟环境在很多方面与现实世界非常相似，这样人们现在就可以开始坐飞机，而不再那么
frightened. Other than exposure therapy, are there any other clinical settings where this is being used? Pain distraction is a big area where VR makes a big difference because if you put somebody in a virtual reality headset, you're occluding their view of the wound site, and while they're getting their daily wound care, say for burn victims, they're engaged in playing a game, and they're in their own world, so to speak, so that what you see from the research is dramatic decreases in the perception of pain, and there's a lot of theory behind why that happens, but it works, and people spend less time between pain delivering sessions, like with the daily wound care, thinking about pain, worrying about pain. So that's one area where
害怕了。除了暴露疗法之外，还有其他使用它的临床环境吗？疼痛分散是一个很大的领域，VR在其中发挥了巨大作用，因为如果你把一个人戴上虚拟现实头显，你就遮挡了他们对伤口部位的视线，当他们接受日常伤口护理时，比如烧伤患者，他们正忙着玩游戏，可以说是身处自己的世界中，所以你从研究中看到的是疼痛感的大幅下降，这背后有很多理论支持为什么会这样，但它确实有效，人们在两次提供疼痛的治疗之间，比如日常伤口护理，花在思考疼痛、担心疼痛上的时间变少了。所以这是我们看到
We've seen dramatic clinical results. We also see results in assessment, you know, where we're putting people in simulated environments and asking them to respond in a cognitive fashion. So, for example, with children with attention deficit, hyperactivity disorder, we've built virtual classrooms where we can put kids in the classroom. They have to pay attention to what goes on
显著临床结果的领域之一。我们也看到了在评估方面的结果，你知道的，我们将人们置于模拟环境中并要求他们以认知的方式做出反应。例如，对于患有注意缺陷多动障碍（ADHD）的儿童，我们建造了虚拟教室，可以将孩子们置于教室中。他们必须专注于发生的事情
on the blackboard or what the teacher says. Meanwhile, we got kids sit next to them fidgeting, throwing paper airplanes, maybe a school bus driving by a window. So we can begin to measure cognitive performance under a range of challenges, but also the challenges of the everyday life environment of the classroom, where distraction is a lot different than if you're testing a child in a quiet office environment, you know, the therapist's office or a clinician's office. It sounds like virtual reality therapy has come a long way.
在黑板上或老师说的话。与此同时，我们让孩子们坐在他们旁边扭动身体、扔纸飞机，可能还有校车从窗户旁开过。因此，我们可以在一系列挑战下开始衡量认知性能，同时也面临教室日常环境的挑战，这里的干扰与你在安静的办公室环境中测试儿童时有很大不同，你知道的，治疗师的办公室或临床医生的办公室。听起来虚拟现实疗法已经取得了长足的进步。
How has work with military veterans, particularly those who served in Iraq and Afghanistan encouraged more research into this type of therapy for conditions such as post-traumatic stress disorder. So what happened in around 2003 as the Operation Iraqi Freedom Adventure took place, we started seeing more and more people coming back with PTSD and the military recognized this as well. And so they began to focus on novel treatments, ways to get people. engaged in treatment. And virtual reality was one of those areas where they were well familiar in the military with simulation technology for training, but not for clinical care. So it was new to them, but they started seeing the results from
与退伍军人的合作，特别是那些在伊拉克和阿富汗服役的退伍军人，是如何鼓励对这种疗法进行更多研究，以治疗创伤后应激障碍等病症的？所以大约在2003年，随着伊拉克自由行动的进行，我们开始看到越来越多的人患上PTSD回来，军方也意识到了这一点。因此，他们开始关注新的治疗方法，寻找让人们参与治疗的方法。而虚拟现实就是其中一个领域，军方对用于训练的模拟技术非常熟悉，但对临床护理却不熟悉。所以这对他们来说是新鲜事物，但他们开始看到来自
civilian literature showing that you get a good clinical outcome using virtual reality in this area. So they funded significantly a lot of the basic research to develop these applications and to test them. And so we began building a virtual Iraq and Afghanistan simulation around 2004 and have progressively grown the application based on feedback from clinicians and patients that we've treated and have gone through probably four iterations now to a very high fidelity environment that It has smells. It has...
民间文献的结果表明，在这个领域使用虚拟现实可以获得良好的临床结果。因此，他们大幅资助了大量基础研究，以开发这些应用并进行测试。因此，我们大约在2004年开始构建虚拟伊拉克和阿富汗模拟系统，并根据我们治疗过并经历过该系统的临床医生和患者的反馈，逐步发展该应用，现在可能已经经历了四个迭代，达到一个非常高的保真度环境，它有气味。它有……
Really smells? Yeah. We can... Bad smells. Yeah, not good one. You know, diesel fuel, rotting garbage, burning rubber, things like that. But we created a multi-sensory environment so that we can help a patient who's typically avoidant to go back and confront and process those difficult emotional memories and get a good
真的有气味吗？是的。我们可以……难闻的气味。是的，不是好的气味。你知道，柴油燃料、腐烂的垃圾、燃烧的橡胶之类的事情。但我们创造了一个多感官环境，以便我们可以帮助通常有回避行为的患者回去面对和处理那些困难的情感记忆，并获得良好的
therapeutic outcome. So we're really basing the use of virtual reality on the evidence-based treat. of trauma-focused therapy, prolonged exposure, or cognitive processing therapy, or EMDR, where people really are encouraged to confront the things that emotionally hurt them initially and to process them in different ways. So that's an example of where the military has really driven the technology and the application, but now we stand poised to translate that to civilian applications. So the first thing you think of is urban warfare with the police department or firefighters
治疗效果。因此，我们确实将虚拟现实的使用建立在循证治疗的基础上，即创伤集中疗法、持续暴露疗法、认知加工疗法或EMDR，在这些疗法中，人们真的被鼓励去直面最初在情感上伤害他们的事情，并以不同的方式处理它们。因此，这是军方真正推动技术和应用的一个例子，但现在我们准备将其转化为平民应用。所以你首先想到的是警察部门或消防员的城市治安战
or victims of terrorist attacks. We've got the technology to do this, and a lot of that has to do with the urgency of war driving a need to develop better treatments for PTSD in the military population. You have said that virtual reality therapy can help reduce the stigma of mental health treatment. Can you elaborate on that? Why do you think that is? Well, if you look at any virtual reality environment, at first blush, it looks like, you know, call of duty, or it looks like any common game that, you know, people play for entertainment. And our view has always been that if you want to draw a digital generation of service members into treatment, why not use some of the things that they're more comfortable with as a draw? So the idea of using virtual reality to deliver. liver exposure therapy was in one part informed by theory that we knew we were working from an
或者是恐怖袭击的受害者。我们拥有实现这一点的技术，这很大程度上与战争的紧迫性有关，战争推动了为军事人口开发更好的PTSD治疗方法的需求。你曾说过，虚拟现实疗法可以帮助减少对心理健康治疗的污名化。你能详细说明一下吗？你认为为什么会这样？嗯，如果你看任何虚拟现实环境，乍一看，它看起来像，你知道的，使命召唤，或者看起来像人们为了娱乐而玩的任何普通游戏。我们的观点一直是，如果你想吸引数字一代的服务人员接受治疗，为什么不利用一些他们更习惯的东西作为吸引力呢？所以使用虚拟现实来提供暴露疗法的想法，一方面受到我们知道我们正在从传统治疗的证据基础
evidence base with traditional treatment but the other part was the idea of maybe getting a 20 year old that played a lot of video games growing up to look at this and say wow you know I can I can maybe get some help and this almost almost kind of looks like fun but in reality once they try it. It's not a game anymore. Right, right. Because we're really, we're really pushing them to. But it gets them in the door a little easier. Yes. Yes. So, and I think, you know, you can say the same thing in the future for, for everybody, whether they're service members or not. Millennials, the current generation, younger generation coming up, you know, this is a ubiquitous
中获取经验的理论的启发，但另一方面也是为了让一个20岁、从小玩很多电子游戏的年轻人看到这一点并说，哇，你知道的，我或许可以得到一些帮助，这几乎看起来像是在玩游戏，但实际上，一旦他们尝试了。这不再是一个游戏了。对，对。因为我们真的，我们真的在推动他们。但这让他们更容易进门。是的。是的。所以，我认为，你知道的，未来对于每个人来说，无论他们是不是军人，你都可以这么说。千禧一代，当前这一代，正在成长起来的年轻一代，你知道的，这是一个无处不在的
technology that they see everywhere. You know, clinicians at their peril may ignore this because they feel it may impair the therapist's client relationship. But actually, in some cases, I think it brings the therapist to a closer understanding of what the client has gone through. When a client is going through a simulation of a traumatic event, for example, the therapist is seeing it. I mean, they're seeing what the patient sees in the simulation, and then that becomes grist for the mill for discussion. And, you know, we are basing it on a traditional, you know, face-to-face format where the whole session isn't conducted in VR. There's, you know, 30 minutes in VR, and the rest of the session is processing what went on in the session. When a patient describes a scene and the clinician has a control panel where they can make elements of that description appear in the simulation,
他们随处可见的技术。临床医生如果忽视这一点，可能会自食其果，因为他们觉得这可能会损害治疗师与客户的关系。但事实上，在某些情况下，我认为这使治疗师更深入地了解客户所经历的事情。例如，当客户经历创伤事件的模拟时，治疗师正在观看。我的意思是，他们看到了患者在模拟中看到的东西，然后这就成了讨论的素材。而且，你知道的，我们是基于传统的、你知道的，面对面的形式，整个会话并非完全在VR中进行。你知道的，有30分钟在VR中，其余时间用于处理会话中发生的事情。当患者描述一个场景，而临床医生有一个控制面板，可以使该描述的元素出现在模拟中时，
all of a sudden, they're looking at it themselves and they're hearing the sounds of, maybe somebody screaming after an IED goes off or a jet flying over. And, you know, I think in some way, they're getting closer to the patient compared to just the patient's narration as they imagine it in their head. Well, great, Dr. Rizzo, thank you so much for joining us. Okay, thank you. Thanks for having me. To see video examples of Dr. Rizzo's work, please visit our website at speakingofpsychology.org.
突然之间，他们自己正在看着它，并听到了声音，也许是简易爆炸装置（IED）爆炸后有人在尖叫，或者喷气式飞机飞过。而且，你知道的，我认为在某种程度上，与患者在脑海中想象的叙述相比，他们离患者更近了。好的，太好了，里佐博士，非常感谢您加入我们。好的，谢谢。谢谢邀请我。要观看里佐博士工作的视频示例，请访问我们的网站 speakingofpsychology.org。
With the American Psychological Association, speaking of psychology, I'm Audrey Hamilton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
与美国心理学会合作，这里是《心理学话语》，我是奥黛丽·汉密尔顿。该剧集尚无评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可留下评论。